[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui
grâce aux témoignages de caroline
d'arione jeunes yvelinoise nous allons
aborder un sujet sensible
méconnu est particulièrement choquant
voilà elle a eu le courage de parler
nous la recevons aujourd'hui ce sujet
c'est celui de la soumission chimique
caroline derrière bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation avec
plaisir vous êtes là parce que vous avez
écrit un livre un livre témoignage on
peut dire ça voilà ça s'appelle et j'ai
cessé de t'appeler papa quand la
soumission chimique fera qu'une famille
en est chez lattès voilà ce livre est
sorti ya quelques semaines voilà alors
ces histoires difficiles choquant et
vous avez décidé de parler oui alors on
y va racontez nous comment comment elle
est arrivée dans votre vie qu'est ce qui
est arrivé le 2 novembre 2020 ma maman
m'appelle après avoir accompagné son
mari au commissariat de carpentras
ils sont tous les deux convoqués à
priori pour des raisons administratives
ils ont dit rendre tous les deux et puis
quelques heures plus tard dans l'âme on
va ressortir seul entre deux c'est 50 50
ans de vie commune qui sont totalement
balayé puisque ce jour-là au
commissariat on va devoir lui apprendre
que son mari la drogue régulièrement
depuis dix ans pour abuser d'elle et la
faire abuser par d'autres hommes c'est
ça qui est terrible il avait mis en
place un mécanisme selon micky avait lic
pour donc comment il faisait pour la
droguer alors on apprend rapidement au
gré de l'instruction peut il la drogue
en mélangeant des somnifères et des
anxiolytiques d'accord qu'il met parfois
dans son bar de table parfois dans son
café noir le matin parfois même dans la
nourriture
et en disant voilà c'est à peu près 70
auteurs 70
violeur viol agresseurs
qui ont bénéficié de ce protocole
d'accord donc oui sainte il anticipait
vraiment à la perfection voit dès le
matin il se disait ce soir je veux
qu'elle soit drogués donc quitte à petit
dans la journée il introduisait ces
médicaments pour la mettre dans un état
d'inconscience mais au risque de la tuer
c'est c'était souvent évidemment
prémédité bien sûr organisé au
millimètre près
c'est ce n'était pas dans la journée du
soir au matin bien vide est atteint il
prépare l état de votre mère ton état
psychique est en tout cas il savait
pertinemment le jour où il allait
agir bien sûr parce qu'il l'a droguée
rarement pour son plaisir personnel oui
alors c'est ça que encore plus immondes
et c'est vraiment l'indicible avez-vous
bref
donc comment comment il faisait pour
recruter des complices alors ce que l'on
sait c'est que il rentrer en contact
avec ces auteurs vers un site internet
qui est d'ailleurs aussi dans d'autres
affaires
claudel final selon ce site qui
s'appelle coco pourrait faire qui a un
vieux site des années 2000 où c'est très
facile finalement se créer un pseudo sur
lequel on entre par exemple sous le code
postal donc ils rentrer en contact avec
ces personnes là en ayant créé un forum
intitulé à son insu la trouver
voilà ils partageaient des photos des
vidéos d'elle pour appâter le chaland si
je puis dire et ensuite les discussions
se poursuivaient par téléphone et ses
auteurs étaient guidés téléguidé jusqu'à
la maison de parents par texto mis
d'accord et alors parmi tous ces
criminels y en a 70 ans vous dites il y
en a 49 je crois incarcéré à le
heureusement aujourd'hui sont à 50
avaient été ré avoir été interpellé et
écroué ducrocq est d'accord et il avait
quel âge quel type 2 alors là aussi
c'est totalement déroutant puisque en
fait
la cinquantaine d'auteurs mêmes même les
70 cents à priori ont entre 22 ans au
moment des faits espace jusqu'à soixante
dix ans ce sont des gens clairement bien
insérés dans la société qui ont le
parfait profil du bon citoyen du bon
père de famille du bon copain que vous
invite auriez bien volontiers à table et
sans avoir aucun soupçon c'était
exactement le profil de votre père oui
c'est ça ils ont quelques sociale tous
ce point en commun d'être absolument
bien insérés social serviable bien
perçue par l'entourage d'accord et
justement en parlant de perception vous
n'êtes jamais posé de questions parce
que votre maman vous le dit dans le
livre elle a quand même eu beaucoup d'
amnésie elle était inquiète elle a vu
trois neurologue c'est vous qui l'avait
poussé à consulter j'imagine oui on a
régulièrement on avait notre maman dans
un état second on constatait par exemple
qu'elle ne se souvenait pas les
conversations qu'on avait eu la veille
voire parfois même le matin même
donc évidemment on s'était inquiété nous
ses trois enfants et on lui a demandé
d'aller consulter ce qu'elle a fait elle
a consulté comme vous dites 3 neurologue
qu'ils ont
diagnostiqué un neurologue lui a
diagnostiqué un opus à musique cérébrale
sauf qu'on en fait jamais plusieurs
c'est espèce de trou noir c'est ponctuel
ces trous noirs c'est ça
d'autres ont mis ça sur le compte dans
tera anxieux on lui a quand même fait
faire un scalaire qui a bien sûr jamais
rien révéler
mais elle a aussi vu bien sûr elle
continuait à avoir ses examens de
routine de voir son médecin généraliste
de voir son gynécologue et le corps
médical elle avait des problèmes gicquel
gynécologique pardon elle en a eu
récurrents elle en a eu sûrement dû à
ces attaques
elle en a eu mais si vous voulez ce
n'était pas facilement perceptible en
tout cas le corps médical n'a pas su
détecter ce que ma mère subissait au
quotidien très bien donc ça veut bien
dire ce que ça veut dire c'est que c'est
complètement méconnu des médecins et les
policiers qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit par
rapport à ce fait absolument effroyable
il connaissait ce genre de non visités
fin de crime non je pense que les
officiers de police quel qu'il soit
aujourd'hui sont absolument pas
sensibilisés à ce type de ce type de
soins en tout cas à ce fait de société
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que si cette affaire est
extraordinaire dans les faits dans la
durée par noms d'auteurs concernées
la soumission chimique en france ne se
restreint pas un verre de ghb l'aa du
ghb la drogue du viol alors voilà
aujourd'hui c'est la soumission chimique
domestique comme vous dites dans un
cadre familial s'est rendue possible par
l'armoire à pharmacie par des
médicaments qu'on délivre sur ordonnance
et qui sont finalement assez facile à
configurer facilement il faut quand même
une ordonnance et c'est pas anodin mais
moi je peux me faire passer pour
quelqu'un dépressive avec ça oui bien
sûr et puis me retrouvais avec une liste
de somnifères et d'anxiolytiques
d'accord mais ce médecin il a pas trouvé
c'est un petit peu récurrent
elle a quand même avalé une dose du
médicament sur plusieurs années certes
mais c'est moi énorme oui alors après
c'était lui qui se faisait prescrire les
médicaments
aujourd'hui il ya des instructions qui
est en cours on cherche à savoir
précisément comment il a pu se procurer
autant déjà des médicaments
parce que ça pose la question aussi du
contrôle de la délivrance de certains
médicaments
donc voilà on espère que l'instruction
nous permettra d'y voir clair en tout
cas d'accord écoutez bon j'imagine une
fois qu'on apprend ça on s'effondre
c'est un tsunami vous avez une famille
vous avez deux frères vous avez un petit
garçon
du jour au lendemain il ya plus de père
il ya plus grand père votre fils a été
suivi par un psychologue il en avait
suivi il est suivi tout d'abord on est
suivi lui comme moi bien sûr c'est
important d'être pris en charge parce
que effectivement c'est un processus de
deuil qui s'est enclenchée moi mon père
comme son grand père n'est pas mort il
en prison puis aura un procès voilà
aujourd'hui mon petit garçon est
beaucoup trop jeune pour comprendre
exactement ce qui se passe mais c'est
certain que ça fait aussi partie de son
héritage familial donc ça aussi il faut
apprendre à les gérer donc oui bien sûr
ça reste une épreuve d'accord alors
justement qu'est-ce que vous avez
décidez vous avez décidé de tout dire je
vois dans le livre par les deux autres
d'humiliation mais finalement c'est ton
talent et elle est complètement abolie
une fois qu'on a tout dit pour moi ce
livre c'est une façon justement de faire
changer la route de caen voilà c'était
important pour moi ce livre sa hotte si
enfin il a aussi une fonction
thérapeutique parce que effectivement
quand ma mère m'appelle le 2 novembre
moi je le vis comme une déflagration
s'est c'est terrible parce que j'étais
amie euh de m'imaginer de la présente et
qui était véritablement mon père l'homme
qui m'a élevé avec lequel j'avais des
liens de proximité des liens de
confiance balade on s'est toutes ces
fondations mais fondation qui s'écroule
à ce moment là je sais très vite que
expert va me permettre de pouvoir
dépasser
le choc traumatique parce que ça reste
un choc traumatique yeux et puis surtout
j'ai à coeur décrit hier pour
pour finalement partager ce fait de
société parce que je vais la prendre en
investiguant en me renseignant que
finalement c'est beaucoup plus répondu
qu'on ne le croit voilà ce qu'il ya
aussi c'est que par exemple votre mère
elle était
rendue complètement elle était
complètement affaibli par ces doses de
médicaments d'eau qu'elle ne conduisait
plus j'imagine qu'elle voyait plus grand
montre votre père avait une emprise
totale ce qui faisait barrage
quelquefois même au téléphone oui enfin
disons que c'était une emprise qui était
tellement bien installé qu'elle est est
imperceptible bien sûr même pour ma
propre mère voilà c'est ça dont tu veux
savoir que ça ça arrive à d'autres
femmes parce que votre père a tenté de
faire des émules il a même donné la
recette du cocktail de médicaments et ça
a marché il ya d'autres criminels qui
qui qui ont fait la même chose avec leur
propre femme alors ces femmes là elles
apprennent ça quand on n'a aucun soutien
rien qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
porte plainte est ce combat ce qui est
sûr c'est que quand on ne se souvient
pas de ce qu'on a fait la veille
de ce qui s'est passé à quel moment on a
décroché perdu connaissance
il faut parler parler c'est déjà la
première étape vers le processus de
prise en charge après bien sûr c'est
compliqué pour certaines des victimes de
se rendre dans un commissariat d'avoir à
déposer plainte et pourtant là aussi
c'est hyper important parce que sans
dépôt de plainte on ne peut pas être
relayées vers une obtiennent légal on ne
peut pas bénéficier des analyses
toxicologiques
ah oui à titre gratuit via bord alors
porté plainte pour ce faire analyser si
on a un doute
d'accord il faut poser ne pas porter
plainte ce qui est logique comme ça ça
va mal par une plainte on peut on peut
on peut se tourner vers un laboratoire
spécialisé c'est pas un laboratoire en
ville d'accord c'est pas ces sont pas
des circuits classiques ce sont des
laboratoires privés qui sont d'où la
difficulté encore plus renforcé quoi
c'est ça et c'est surtout que c'est
quand même des analyses toxicologiques
qui coûte relativement cher je comprends
ok donc finalement vous quand vous dites
très bien de cette boue je veux en faire
une belle matière vous en fait un combat
aujourd'hui vous avez envie de mener des
actions de vous rapprocher de la cause
des femmes et que ce soit sue connus
reconnus
bâclé show sera que je pense qu'il ya il
est nécessaire d'alerter
sur ce qu'est la soumission chimique
aujourd'hui en france de prévenir pour
mieux protéger
il est c'est hyper important de pouvoir
bénéficier des bonnes structures pour
être prises en charge à la fois sur le
plan psychologique médico social et
judiciaire aussi parce que quand on
tournait dans ce genre de
situation ça veut dire des peuples 1 ça
veut dire aussi pouvoir être accompagnés
sur le plan juridique judiciaire
voilà donc il ya des structures
aujourd'hui en france qui existe qui
sont formés à la prise en charge du choc
traumatique aussi parlé de la maison des
femmes par exemple la maison des femmes
en fait partie à la maison des femmes
c'est ça a été créé par une femme qui
par le docteur rade atenza qui a créé la
première maison des femmes en 2016 et
aujourd'hui la maison des femmes c'est
un collectif
plusieurs maisons des femmes qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de s'ouvrir
qui sont systématiquement à dossier à un
hôpital dans toutes les grandes villes
de france aujourd'hui ce sont des
structures qui sont formés pour
accueillir la prise de parole en tout
cas la prise en charge au sens large je
comprends médical psychologique
juridique et juridique bien sûr
médico-social ancien peut être aussi
parce que du jour au lendemain votre
mère s'est retrouvée sans maison criblée
de dettes parce que aussi pour en
rajouter une couche votre père avait
fait d'énormes emprunt à son nom elle
n'aurait pas eu ses enfants elle était à
la rue à la fin ça peut être ça aussi
pour d'autres personnes kouassi non mais
disons que
maman lui la chance d'avoir ses enfants
ses cieux sans ça de toute façon
ce qui a été le plus compliqué pour elle
c'était de redémarrer sa vie à 69 ans à
0 comment va-t-elle elle va bien elle va
bien elle est maman c'est quelqu'un qui
est tourné vers le positif
puis vous savez elle va voir 70 ans donc
il lui reste dix belles années elle veut
en profiter qu'elle soit vraiment belle
mais avec ses enfants et qui la
soutiennent caroline darian un grand
merci alors j'encourage tout le monde à
lire ce livre parce qu'il faut savoir
c'est important bravo pour votre combat
et bonne chance à très bientôt j'espère
au revoir les temps voire caroline
[Musique]